hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2017 chinese drama and fantasy movie
called hanson and the beast
the movie begins with a skinny man named
hanson who seems like being chased by a
mysterious creature in the middle of the
night
the creature eventually corners him and
hanson accidentally falls down with
severe scratch wounds on his thigh
the scene goes back 36 hours before the
incident when hanson tries to date a
woman from a wealthy family hoping that
she would pay off his debt he claims
that he is not willing to do sexual
intercourse after the wedding which
makes the woman furious
she scolds him for his poor academic
background and then gives her sister's
number since he is quite handsome
he is offended and walks away while
bringing the cake with him
turns out that hansen works as an
elephant keeper in solidarity zoo
that night he gets a message from a
representative from the dating app he
has been using saying that they have
found another rich woman the next
morning hansen calls his dad who has
suffered mental health problems and
always sees his son as a special agent
suddenly a group of nurses shows up and
one of them warns hansen to pay the bill
or his dad will be expelled
he arrives at a coffee shop where a
young beautiful woman named xiaobei
randomly approaches him and somehow
knows his name
she acts strange while stating that she
has been looking for him for so long
hansen is terrified when she reveals
that she is a fox
he immediately runs into the toilet but
is later confronted by gangsters who
forcibly take him out of the coffee shop
it is revealed that hanson owed the
gangsters 2 million yuan
in the evening xiao bay pays a visit to
hanson's place but he is frightened when
the woman manages to locate the scars on
his chest
turns out that hansen once protected
shia bay while she was in her white fox
form and that's when he got the scars
since hanson still doesn't believe her
the woman attempts to transform to prove
that she is indeed a fox
after consuming several bottles of beer
xiao bay finally transforms into a white
fox
hanson is so scared and escapes from his
place after the fox tears his clothes
meanwhile a man from the bureau of
transfiguration or bot an organization
specializing in researching unique
creatures spots xiao bay illegally
transforming in the human world and
orders the others to capture her the
drunk fox chases after the topless
zookeeper to the top of a building until
hanson gets cornered and hopelessly
tries to touch the fox but she startles
him causing him to fall down luckily the
bot agents arrive on time and rescue
hansen
they release devices that wipe the
witness's memory xiao bay destroys the
device just before it reaches hanson as
she doesn't want his memory about her
erased a few moments later xiao bay
loses consciousness due to drinking too
much alcohol so the agents take her away
while leaving hanson alone
six hours later hanson returns home and
is confronted by the gangsters again
he feels like he is hallucinating and
suddenly goes crazy but xiaobei appears
to protect her lover
however the gangsters and hanson run
away in fear after the woman transforms
his head into a fox's head
bot agents detect xiao bay illegally
transforming again and immediately send
the memory wiper device to the scene
luckily xiaobay manages to find hanson
just before he gets bitten by the device
she awkwardly tells hansen that she
loves him and wants to marry him to
repay his kindness
however the zookeeper makes it clear
that he saved her only by accident at
that time
on the other side commissioner yoon of
bot visits the agents and questions
captain hong's capability to capture
xiaobei
he explains that xiaobei's fox form is a
rare breed and warns captain hong not to
let her get polluted by humans
back to hansen he meets a daughter from
a wealthy family who is willing to marry
him and help his financial problem but
xiaobei suddenly shows up and ruins the
atmosphere not allowing hansen to date
another woman
hansen desperately reveals that he has
no other choice but to marry a rich
woman because he urgently needs to pay
off his debt still that evening
commissioner yun approaches hanson and
explains the history of the creature
whose genetics were brought by an alien
spaceship and then mutated with earth's
ecosystem creating the most intelligent
being on earth including xiaobei who now
lives alongside humans
yoon gives a special syringe to hansen
hoping that he would assist them to
capture xiaobei
in exchange yoon will give him a lot of
money which will be enough for hansen to
pay his dad and live a decent life
hansen goes to an amusement park where
xiaobei approaches him and gives him
money gaining money from picking up
trash there however hanson states that
it is useless and makes xiaobei
desperate even though he has the
opportunity to inject the liquid he
doesn't do it
instead he tells her about how he lost
two million yuan after getting
blackmailed by a fan
to grant more money for her lover xiao
bay goes to a nightclub and acts as a
dancer
she manages to impress the rich man but
suddenly hanson appears and takes her
away
as they walk hanson scolds her for
selling herself showing that he indeed
cares for her
he then reveals about his rendezvous
with jun
xiaobei makes it clear that it is fine
to inject her as long as the debt will
be paid but he refuses and kisses her
instead
they return to hanson's place and
conduct a brief wedding ceremony
meanwhile commissioner yun is informed
about her location and immediately heads
over to the club as well but cannot find
the white fox however he coincidentally
discovers a woman who is illegally
interacting with humans
she tries to attack him causing yun to
lose his temper and eliminate her
back to the couple
bot agents surround hansen's place and
attempt to arrest xiaobei for breaking
the law
yun captain hong and his agents also
present there hong creates a scene to
buy some time allowing the couple to run
away but not for so long
the fight ensues until june threatens to
kill hansen
xiao bay has no choice but to kneel down
and allows herself to be captured by bot
luckily the gangsters randomly show up
and distract the agents
xiaobei uses this opportunity to
transform and runs away with hansen the
commissioner chases after them and fires
an arrow which hits the fox's back
xiao bay's friend bing bing picks them
up and treats her deep wound
the agents manage to locate her so bing
bing brings the couple to a movie
shooting studio
the director feels suspicious about a
man which turns out to be young
disguised as a royal family member as he
has not seen him before and his makeups
are terrible but the shooting of the
fighting scene eventually continues
shiaobe realizes that bot agents are in
the studio so she takes hanson with her
and tries to escape
however yoon plays dirty and brings
hanson's father to lure him which is
successful
xiao bay sees them and walks toward
hanson
she grabs his hand and deliberately
injects the liquid to her neck
three months after the incident hansen
has become a rich man and he is now able
to move his dad into a decent room in
the hospital
despite having abundant money he still
misses shia bay and is willing to risk
everything to find her hanson returns to
his old place where he accidentally
finds captain hong who blames him for
injecting the poison into xiao bay after
a brief fight hong finds a way to break
into the prison and brings hansen to a
restaurant where the restaurant owner
mack overs hansen making him look
exactly the same as commissioner yun
afterward they get into a fridge that
transports them directly to the prison
through an underground tunnel they meet
the manager of the prison who turns out
to be jun's brother-in-law
he is confused about fake jun's behavior
but has no choice but to obey his
command the manager takes hansen to
xiaobay's cell
however she doesn't seem to recognize
her husband even after he reveals his
disguise
she attacks hansen while he tries to
talk to her
hanson shows her their marriage sign and
apologizes for being a useless partner
and it seems like shia bae slowly
remembers him
not long after hong intervenes and they
attempt to take xiaobei out
unfortunately they come across the real
commissioner yun which makes the guards
confused
just after the real commissioner reveals
his wings xiao bay breaks free and
accidentally removes hansen's mask
when yoon is about to kill hanson while
streaming it live several prisoners
escape from their cell and distract
everyone in the room
turns out that they are actually humans
who are victims of false arrest during
the shooting sequence earlier in the
studio one of them climbs up and
stupidly pulls down the lever which
unlocks every cell in the prison
the situation becomes chaotic as the
prisoners emerge and attack the guards
commissioner yun even has to step in to
deal with the prisoners
at this point xiao bay finally regains
her consciousness but still barely
recognizes her husband
hanson distracts yon and hong uses this
opportunity to take him down a few
moments later the batter dune grabs a
knife and attempts to kill xiao bay but
the knife hits hanson instead who tries
to protect her
xiao bay who finally remembers hansen
becomes furious and effortlessly throws
the commissioner out of the building the
following day yoon is seen arrested and
is now under mental status examination
while captain hong gets a promotion and
allows the marriage between their race
and humans however he still hardly
accepts the fact that his crush xiaobei
chose hanson over him
meanwhile hanson survived the attack and
the couple now live a happy life
together
at the end of the movie the couple are
blessed with a child
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching